the dramatic rescue of a woman lost in a
forest for 17 days is bringing new hope
for finding another missing hiker on the
same Island 35 year-old Noah Mena was
reported missing in Maui last Monday
Amanda eller who was rescued on Friday
celebrated the end of her ordeal with
family friends and rescuers yesterday
Jonathan Vigliotti was at the emotional
reunion he's in pea
Maui near the site of the party Jonathan
how are hurt spirits and good morning to
you Anthony spoke with Amanda LR at that
party briefly and I gotta say I was so
struck by her composure and her warmth
she says she is doing great her spirits
are high but make no mistake about it
she's got a long road to recovery her
legs were heavily bandaged and her feet
so swollen she couldn't walk still weak
from 17 days and 16 nights in the
Hawaiian jungle Amanda eller arrived at
her party with a little help from her
family and friends I'm just the girl
that got lost in the woods and you guys
like showed up hard they called her
rescue a miracle on Monday they treated
her like a hero I just have so much
gratitude and thanks for like everybody
showing up with the biggest hearts and
the biggest generosities those
volunteers kept showing up some climbing
some repelling some flying drones even
when police called off the search after
just three days she just went through
the 17 day survivor ordeal and she's
looking unbelievable Ehlers good friend
Javier cantaloupes last saw her on
Friday when he was part of the team that
spotted her from the air and then
rescued her from a jungle waterfall
she's like you never gave up on me I was
like I was gonna search for you for the
rest of my life
guys we're not gonna give up on me thank
God
many of the guests at this party never
met eller before but that didn't stop
them from putting their lives on hold to
make sure she survived to deliver an
inspiring message to the world we should
all be able to enjoy every single moment
of every single day of this life and
maybe my story will help a couple of
people to do that and LR is slowly
regaining her strength she wasn't able
to eat solid food over the weekend last
night at that party she was eating fish
tacos she was asked if she would ever
return unto that area where she got lost
to that park and she very quickly said
no and I don't think she was kidding
[Laughter]
take your word for it
Jonathan we mentioned another hiker is
missing in the same area what more can
you tell us about that yeah as Amanda's
family celebrates another family is
desperately looking for a missing man in
fact a few days before Amanda was found
alive a man went missing and another
park here on this island we spoke with
pilots the ones that we rode with over
the weekend one of them is actually now
tasked with this search effort as it
remains very much ongoing today we hope
they have the same success Jonathan
thank you